اهلا وسهلا بكم دكتور جهاد اسعور عبر سي
ان بالعربيه دعني ابدا معك بالسؤال عن
التقرير الذي اثرتموه مؤخرا كصندوق نقل
دولي ما هي اسباب صلابه النشاط الاقتصادي
في المنطقه رغم الظروف الراهنه والمحيطه
العالميه بالواقع كما تفضل النمو
الاقتصادي لهذا العام يفوق المعدلات الدول
المتقدمه اللي عدده اسباب ااه يعود الامر
للتحسن الاقتصادي لشهدته الدول المصدره
للنفط بالدرجه الاولى
مع ارتفاع اسعار النفط ارتفاع الانتاج
بالاضافه الى التحسن التي شهدته
الاقتصادات العام الماضي وهذا العام
ملك في انه بالاضافه للتحسن الاقتصادي
هناك مخاطر اقتصاديه كمان يجب الاضاءه
عليها ارتفاع معدلات التضخم وخاصه انه هذا
التضخم مصحوب بارتفاع اسعار المواد
الاوليه واسعار الطاقه
والمتغيرات بالاسواق الماليه العالميه
التي تؤثر سلبا على الدول التي تحتاج الى
التمويل الخارجي كان بسبب ارتفاع اسعار
الفوائد او بسبب تحول رؤوس الاموال لهذا
السبب بالرغم من التحسن اللي همم يشهدوا
اقتصاد المنطقه اه من الضروره التحوط
والتخاذ الاجراءات اللازمه لحمايه
الاقتصاد كيف يبدو المشهد في الدول ذات
الاقتصادات الصاعده حاليا الدول المصدره
للنفسه شهدت نمو اقتصادي افضل همم من
الدول المستورده
وكان نسبه النمو بحوالي 5.2%
هذا النمو سيستمر ان مسامير خفيف في العام
المقبل
وسيكون النمو للقطاع الغير نفطي اقوى من
نمور قطاع النفط الدول المستورده للنفط
اوضاع او الدول الناشئه تاثرت بسبب ارتفاع
التضخم الذي فاق العشره في المئه في عدد
كبير من الدول ومراجع ان يستمر للعام
المقبل بالاضافه الى ان هذه الدول اليوم
بحاجه الى تمويل همم
الديون التي تستحق لذا تتاثر بارتفاع
اسعار الفوائد عالميه مما لا شك فيه انه
حاله عدم اليقين والترقب التي يشهد
الاقتصاد العالمي تؤثر على مجمل دول
العالم دول المنطقه ايضا
[موسيقى]
كان في هناك اتفاق على صعيد فريق العمل مع
الحكومه اللبنانيه اللي وضع
الحصول على برنامج بتطلب مجموعه من
الاجراءات لبنان بالقيام بهذه الاجراءات
هناك بعض الاجراءات التي
يعمل عليها لبنان
من خلال برنامج
حاليا في فراغ سياسي
وبنفس الوقت وقعت الحكومه اللبنانيه مؤخرا
ايضا على اتفاق ترسيم الحدود مع اسرائيل
ما تاثير هذا الاتفاق وكيف يبدو المستقبل
بالنسبه للاقتصاد اللبناني عدتني موضوع
ترسيم الحدود هو له علاقه
بالاقتصاد اللبناني على المدن المتوسط
الاوضاع الراهنه تتطلب يعني عمليه اولا
المحافظه على الاستقرار الاقتصادي
اجراء هذه المجموعه من
الاصلاحات اللي هي اساسي اللي هي من شاننا
انه ترجع ترد
المشاكل الاقتصاديه والمجتماعيه المزمنه
همم درجه من الاحتضان الاجتماعي وخاصه
للفئات الاكثر ضعفا
واعاده اطلاق الاقتصاد اللبناني
ليامن فرص العمل هذه اذا بدك الاولاويات
الاقتصاديه والاجتماعيه الاساسيه اللي بت
طب بالطبع التحسن او بيئه سياسه همم يعني
مؤتي
[موسيقى]